bonjour bonjour
maïté quelle recette du festin
aujourd'hui on va faire deux sorties de
brochettes de sanglier au sol idéal
sanglier c'est bien de votre région ça
il y en a il y en a beaucoup on peut pas
dire qu'elle a beaucoup mais yann à
alors chaque année vous faites des
civets vous êtes des terrines on a déjà
fait les terrines de civet et civet du
rôti là maintenant faire des bronches
des brochettes et on va faire deux
recettes de brochettes qui sont des
recettes très traditionnel puisque on
les trouve déjà dans le dictionnaire de
cuisine d'alexandre dumas de conseils
scolaires on est certainement mangé
alors la différence et qui a deux
marinas et 2 marinade différente tout à
fait et ça on va l'expliquer au fur et à
mesure de la recette
alors où la première que nous faut-il
commencer jaurès l'honneur et on a fait
à préparer une marinade et bien
valorisée s'est jouée dans laquelle on a
mis de l'huile de livres exactement du
vin rouge dû larguer du thym de la
menthe et de la soul c'est très bien et
puis alors là vous avez du poivre et
cuire à l'eau alors il ya des carottes
il ya du terrain du laurier il ya de la
vente reste il ya du paprika et les
tours 2 0
il ya des citrons il ya évidemment le
sel poivre du sel huile
il ya les côtes de sanglier et la viande
pour faire des brochettes de sanglier et
bien vous allez nous montrer comment
vous faites tout ça mais bien sûr on
fini de couper la viande pour les
brochettes
d'ailleurs le chandelier voilà et je
vais le mettre à mariner
la voilà il faudra laisser combien de
temps dans l'amont 24 heures 24 heures
et les bars sûrs que vous avez de quoi
ré que va-t-on en faire et bien les
parures on va s'en servir vous allez
voir ça pour le fond de sauce nous
supposons 24 heures sont passées pour la
marinade et maintenant vous découpez les
bars les parures
marthe 5 comme on dit chez nous vous
voulez que je voudrais être un peu de
graisse de canard a choisi dans la
cocotte
si vous voulez pendant vous découpez ça
c'est du sanglier
et oui il est coriace il a dû courir
quand vous allez faire votre marché dans
volant ni vous arrive de voir des
sangliers dans la forêt mais bien sûr et
ce matin encore des chevreuils à nant
des sangliers c'est plus rare et il ya
beaucoup d'activités avec des sangliers
aussi c'est bon voilà je crois que c'est
pas mauvais quand je porte je leur mets
sur le feu la mariant d' que je vais
mettre parce qu'il fait est assez fort
quitte à vous de voir la séparation
c'est bon là je vais saler poivrer
bien sûr tout ça n'est pas vrai ou faux
toujours saler poivrer
ça va bien revenir dans la ligue 1 l'as
roma du sel et du poivre dans son salon
la wii fait qu'une recette nous la
montre ou comme ça mais en fait il
faudrait parce que la communauté l'avant
veille il faut comment elle a commencé
la veille est le bienvenu enfants vont
expliquer pourquoi regarder faut que la
marinade 24 ans suit avant la cuisson
nous allons voir comme s'il obtiendrait
lui relate au forfait repas grandes
choses et salades on avait dit de
laisser l'autre veut lâcher mon petit
couteau il a une meilleure je crois vous
pour la seule grosse erreur et ça fait
rire chez notre loterie et honda se
tenir au symbole des 60 ans un petit peu
le prouve sa fonction vivier faille dans
les vieilles recettes des mousquetaires
et surtout du vieux livres qu'on a donné
du xviie siècle s'aperçoit qu'on mettait
énormément néfice évidemment on se dit
que probablement la viande sans faire
c'est l'euphorie saleh a remarqué mme
bout à l'autre sans temps de chauffe et
la laisser vieillir un coq au vin tout
la voix boréales heures ensuite
ensuite je crois que vous vouliez vous
servir de cela on va se servir de ça je
vais sortir libre revenir avec
l'écumoire voilà je vais me les mettre
dans cette assiette
oui et je vais me servir de ce jus il va
recouvrir
vous allez voir où nous carcasse et nous
parut intégrer ces morceaux ça c'est
pour faire la sauce ça c'est pour faire
la sauce valable la marinade
je vais y laisser le thym et le laurier
ni je le reste dedans
voilà et je vais me porter ceci est dans
ceux là que je m'exprime bien il y est
vous allez verte est la variable deux
heures la voile à essaouira vous m'avez
dit que ça fait au moins deux événements
alors là il n'y a pas beaucoup de jus
oui mais c'est pour ça qu'ils vont faire
tout se vend et bien en tout temps leur
est pas ce que l'on a de quoi laisser
réduire
on va leur ouvrir et passion et patience
je vais baisser le gas capitale
et pendant que la sauce réduit réduit à
tous peut m'aider joie que vous avez
commencé les brochettes les brochettes
alors j'avais coupé quoi là j'ai coupé
du leur et maintenant je vais l'enfiler
et voilà et on va le faire cuire et les
morceaux vous étiez là c'est le morceau
de sanglier qui ont mariné pendant 24
heures dans l'huile vinaigre et beaucoup
de bonnes herbes voilà et maintenant je
vais les porter sur les greens on va lui
demander ce que vivent au feu autrement
pour très bientôt vous rendez vous mais
nous on a la chance d'avoir une cheminée
autant s'en servir
voilà regardez ça tu déjà la viola et
pendant ce temps on va pouvoir regarder
ce que devient à la sauce notre chance
c'est bien sûr on va les surveiller un
petit peu parce que ça peut être vite
expliquant alors la foudre et puis
j'espère oui elle est belle elle est
bien oui bien sûr on va les mettre dans
l'assiette
les parures de sangliers n'ont servi
qu'à donner un bon goût à la sauce
examen dont vous les mangez doit n'en
mangent les brochettes à déjeuner et les
parures au dîner et comme si on a une
journée samedi une journée samedi là et
après je vais prendre ce jus oui là il
faut que j'en ai beaucoup parce que je
suis obligé de répondre ce jus oui même
le même rêve faire passer le monde le
sait c'est mes doigts parce que pas
particulièrement bien avant que l'étang
de lacanau frêche tout de suite et le
laurier je remarque que vous en ayez
toujours quand vous faites des
souverains des sauveurs en demande vous
mettez toujours un peu de crème fraîche
alors que dans certaines recettes on dit
d'hubert vous vous préférez la can frais
préfère la crème fraîche moi parce que
c'est l'hallali en même temps oui l'art
et puis ça fait beaucoup vraiment
terrible legasse le connais bien
voilà pour que ça vaut bien la voilà
et puis c'est terminé et ça va faire des
alors vous la mettez dans le bol tout
jeter dans le bol tout de suite un
bouillon ça y est bon c'est bon c'est
forcément la bonne je vais le donner
voilà à la louche je vais lever à la
balle et c'est inutile de la passe et on
ne regarde le fond d'échalotes et que ça
devient sur pensionnat pas pouvoir sur
l'autre ça va et je crois qu'il serait
temps d'aller revoir nous rejoindre les
hommes à brochettes dans la cheminée à
la elles sont vraiment belles est
vraiment bien centré jours loin de celle
et bien je vais les finir le en coupures
ou en maintenant ça c'est l'apparition
des envies d'ailleurs mais on a
exactement
voilà vendre la grèce de jambon et la
seconde écoulée sur les brochettes
écoulés sur les prochaines regarder ça
fini ça donne un bon goût vers des
conneries la voilà et vous croyez que
vous allez pouvoir vous les rapporter
sur le soulageant travaux brulin je ne
saute aux yeux de mon coeur que celle là
est très très très attention
ça y est ça va la cre et bien voilà une
brochette ça pour être bien grillé
czudek san jose où je joue je vous le
remettez à rien de sauce au vin un peu
la sauce qui arrivent et je vous savez
c'est beau mais là à sentir il faut le
faire sur la table là bien sûr l'ancien
il faut de la patience pour cette
recette c'est très long supervia en
danger c'est très long bon alors
maintenant la variante on va essayer la
seconde recette pour des brochettes de
la différence entre ces deux recettes de
prochaine grille et l ai pas besoin de
meslier et d'un set avec du lait devant
la marina la marinade avait du verglas
il ya du citron est envahie meurtre du
paprika
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez mis
connaîtra les bateaux vie qu'est ce que
vous avez vu dans cette marinade
on a mis évidemment du vin blanc on a
mis de l'oignon de l'échalote
on a mis deux là y en as mis du
personnel minute un but lors du giro des
carottes
du bien et du oui enfin bref
[ __ ] du ter et le citron et du laurier
et puis voilà et puis voilà bon alors
maintenant qu'est ce que vous allez
faire vous allez partir les morceaux de
viande va sortir les morceaux de viande
on va les mettre là dedans voilà je les
fais avec la mer on appelle ça les
perses universel oui normal et c'est
tout ça vous sortiez au citron citron
ressentez oui parce qu'il faut pas
qu'ils vous le citron oui là il a donné
son goût de toute façon là on va sortir
des deux tranches de citron et on va
faire réduire cette marinade dans la
cocotte
alors est ce que vous faites revenir les
légumes d'abord ou pas oui je vais les
sorties révélé qu on avait d'abord j'y
mets un petit peu de graisses de
graisses bien entendu comme la sauteuse
et chaude ça va très bien ça va être
très bien alors là je prendrai du petit
écran entre je vais couler mes légumes
je n'y vais pas y mettre un gros plan
montre de viande ou les sorties remercie
beaucoup
vous allez les faire suer oui la
syndicaliste avait réduit réduire et du
syndicat n'a de nom juste un peu et on
garde un juge voilà c'est bien ce n'est
ni salé ni quoi briller puisque ça a été
salé poivré
d'abord la marinière et dans la marinade
on va les faire suer un thé un petit peu
et on va ajouter notre petit paprika que
voilà il arrive à beaucoup et est
savamment un goût très différent parce
que la recette n'est pas du tout pareil
drame concerne la souris dans leur
paraît pas bien tout même d'ailleurs la
couleur est pas pareil et l'odeur non
plus une fois que sa juge te suis un peu
est ce que vous y ajoutez la marina on
va jouer marinade jeu parce que ces jeux
voilà il faut pas faire fuir et
tellement voilà oui et on va rajouter
dans vos marinades est terminée ça sera
suffisant vous voulez un peu de
sauternes en plus ça gâche rien
je vous en donne à tout petits pas rien
gâcher le tout ouïe la soupçonne comme
on dit chez moi
un joli soupçon voilà on couvre on l'a
se réduire
au moins une et pendant ce temps
j'imagine que vous allez nous préparer
peut-être les prenant brochettes
[Musique]
elles ont été cuites sur la braise dans
la cheminée passer aux cocus raw ou gras
du rebond oui et maintenant ça va
peut-être regarder où on essaie dessous
enfin les vins blancs
elle est belle voilà vous allez là
passez au chinois aux chinois parce
qu'il n'y en a pas beaucoup appellent
mardi donc jubien réduit 1 réduit ray
différent de la première sortie
intervint rouen serait qu'au bien en
écraser pour avoir un peu de jus et
voyez la différence avec l'autre
quand même oui vous donne le pilon on va
l'écraser il en ressort du oui et là
c'est d'abord aux juges ont eu à jiegu
bien épais si vous par faire une grande
force et c'est juste pour arroser la
branche r et puis ça y est voilà c'est
bon je dois revivre et je vais regarder
vous avez légèrement arrosée ses
branches est alors voilà nous avons
quatre brochette de sangliers deux sont
préparés avec une sauce au vin rouge et
on a ajouté un peu de gelée de
groseilles parce qu'avec l'egypte
d'efforts comme le chevreuil et le
sanglier et pilon les deux autres du
moins s'en fait avec une sauce bronze à
blanc et aux sous terre mais on se rend
compte à l'oeil que c'est quelque chose
de très différent au pays avec une
goutte de citron pour finir et bien des
recettes qui demande assez de patience
il faut bien dire mais les bonnes
recettes pour des jours d'hiver où on
aime bien être au coin de la cheminée
alors vous pouvez essayer
bon courage et à bientôt à bientôt et
bon appétit
[Musique]